الانتخابات التركيه في 2023 انتخابات
مختلفه سياسيا واقتصاديا واجتماعيا هي
المره الاولى التي يواجهوا فيها اردوغان
تحالفا يضم سته احزاب معارضه بينها حزباني
كبيران كما انها ليست منافسه تقليديه بين
اختلافين حاكم ومعارض بقدر ما هي صراع على
تحديد هويه تركيا في قرنها الثاني ومفترق
طريق ستسلكه البلاد باردوغان او بدونه
سواء كانت الانتخابات الرئاسيه او
البرلمانيه الثامنه والعشرين تحظى باهميه
واحده حيث تاتي بعد مرور 100 عام على
تاسيس الجمهوريه التركيه
الطريق الذي ستنتهي به هذه الانتخابات في
حال فاز فيها اردوغان هو طريق قرن جديد
بوعود كبيره من قبل الرئيس التركي وفرصه
لتثبيت مشروعه السياسي اما خساره اردوغان
للرئاسه فقد تعني حقبه جديده داخليا
دستورا واصلاحات جديده وهو ما تساله
المعارضه من خلال الاطاحه باردوغان بهدف
دخول حقبه جديده تبدا بالتراجع عن سياساته
داخليا اي منعطف تسلكه الانتخابات قد يعني
تغيرات توجهات تركيا الخارجيه خاصه ان
الدوره والتاثير التركيه في الشؤون
الدوليه يمثل تحديا للمعارضه فهو شهاده
على انجازات اردوغان عقدان كانت الفتره
الاخيره الاصعب فيهما فقد شهدت فيها تركيا
متغيرات عده اقتصاديه على راسها التضخم
وكذلك كوارث طبيعيه زلزال كان بمثابه
اختبار للرئيس التركي لذا فانما ستقرره
صناديق الاقتراع لن يتعلق فقط بمن سيحكم
لكن بكيفيه الحكم والمسار الاقتصادي الذي
سيسلكه الفائز وسياساته داخليا او خارجيا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات